パワー
今日は外れ社長です今日の twitter 寒いデー
safe
そうだよねおれなんて今日も1日3月さ
今ですね拓海君が僕のように来ています
車で皆さんこういう商品知っていますでしょうかシート貼ってあって申し訳ないんです
けどとリードうんちシールってつか挙げますめっちゃリアルじゃねっていうレベルで
めっちゃ曲やでこれどういう使い道があるかというとただのに立つのグッズではなくて
ちょっと実用的なもの
になっています裏を見てみましょうチャリって左翼かけられないですか
意地だけパクられるとかそういうイタズラがよくあると思うんですけどもこれねじれ
ジャーナリストがに貼るシールですそうするとからみんななんか鳥の[ __ ]なんで落ちてる
自転車なんてべ住みたくないんじゃんだからこのシールを貼ることによってあの盗難の
確率が大幅に減るんだよみたいな感じらしいですこれでも自転車が守れてみたいな装い
で防犯ぐ
その一つになっています
ということは今日の防犯月自転車じゃなくて
車にも使えるんじゃそう思った僕は彼が家の中にいる間に彼の車にプリのうち指導
大量に貼ってみることでしかこうすることによっては彼の車もとても汚く見えるって
あの彼が車が盗まれる確率が大幅に減る泥棒さんも鳥のさんがたくさん落ちているから
待って盗みたいと思わないんでこうすることによってパンが防犯のレベルを上げて彼が
車の盗難に遭う確率大幅に下げてあげよう
というなんとも優しい棄却になっておりますではやってみました
雲よ
[音楽]
ame
me
ben ん
[音楽]
ん
完全で取れなくんですね
それもリアルなやつ隊パッチですこれでたぶん彼の車が盗まれる心配はないと思います
または本人の反応を待ってみましょうでは
おん
ええええええ
んぐっ
行っちゃうんかないっ
me
teame
male
me
ana あああっ
voodoo
襲った
部分の
you do